I love that song this is perfect for
this segment to keeping your home warm
this fall and winter could take a toll
on your family budget households in the
united states say their monthly energy
costs rise from almost ninety six
dollars in 2006 to an average of about
one hundred and fourteen dollars in 2014
that's a big old jump but upgrades in
home technology could help cut the costs
Lindsay Turrentine is the
editor-in-chief of our partners at
cnet.com and she joins us at the table
so you're saying hi Lindsay good morning
so you're saying if you knew exactly
where the energy was coming from you
could save money and you brought a
little handy-dandy gadget I did and do
that right now it's plugged into the
lamp behind me it's a remote switch so
think of it as sort of a timer but it's
got smarts and there's an app on your
phone load the app and you can use the
app to do a couple things you can use it
to control the lamp basic stuff here on
turning it on and off yeah Oh however
you are mo word we're good I'm magical
do that or you can do this from anywhere
but what's really cool about this device
costs fifty dollars you can plug it in
anywhere so any product in your house
you can plug into it and the app itself
tracks your usage and tells you how much
that product is using so you can use
this app to make really smart decisions
there's a writer for cnet who used this
plug and moved it all over his house he
found out that his house was using more
energy than any other house in his
neighborhood and he decided he wanted to
put an end to that he ended up
identifying some old appliances in his
house swapping them out and saving
something like eight hundred fifty
dollars a year just by figuring out
using this app where that energy was
beaches fifty dollars its fifty dollars
and you can buy multiple and control
multiple devices with it sort of like an
advanced timer it's got some cool
features like it will randomize when
your lights come on so that you can
confuse burglars but it also mostly and
what I think is cool lets you track the
energy and if your way set the heating
in your house so about the time you get
that will be warm that's what's right
and you know if you there are lots of
ways to control heat from a distance
well reduce e or reduce heat from a
distance we
in the cnet smart home and all of our
testing and projects take a lot of look
at thermostats we've talked about nest
on this show before there's some other
cool devices there's the Eco be three
which is a smart thermostat that has
something that no other smart
thermostats have remote sensors that you
can place around your house so that you
can actually see where your rooms are
hot or quits the biggest drainer that we
should just get rid of large old
appliances are a huge drainer so you've
probably been to the store you've seen
the Energy Star rating label those
labels actually mean something they mean
that a gadget a product any device has
been shown to save significant energy
over time and that you should be able to
recoup the cost of that new product
relatively quickly yeah a new appliances
if I knew I'd am applying we've got an
avocado refrigerator or something that's
moongold it needs to go it doesn't
matter i got you i mean in some cases I
previews fifty dollars a month got it
popping out Thank You Lindsay you know
you always gonna see you